okay so we've looked at multiplying
indices dividing indices 0 indices
negative indices today last thing what
happens when you have a fraction is one
of these powers okay so how are we going
to consider this let's think of an
example let's think of something like
say 3 and let's put a fraction in the
power we start with an easy one
let's put a ha now my question is my
question is what is this thing equal to
okay now okay now see he's the problem
the whole idea of indices right is like
not a law but it's like a manpower and
means you multiply the number by itself
and you do it you don't have times right
but I don't have a number of like what
does it mean to multiply a number by
itself half a time like that doesn't
make sense
okay so here's the way I'm gonna
approach it I'm gonna think about these
laws and see if I could do something
that'll make sense you suppose which way
shall I take it let's get this one first
one the very first one is impossible if
I were to multiply this number by
another number same base for the purpose
of illustration I'm gonna make the power
the same as well okay three to the power
half times 3 to the power half according
to this first law that we established
ages ago what should I do to the indices
plus I should add them like so well
what's 1/2 plus 1/2 it's just 1 right
hold on see the power of 1 is just 3
like that
and hold on a second what does this mean
we're trying to work out what is three
did haha what is that thing okay now
what we've noticed is that this if you
multiply it by itself you get three what
number do you multiply by itself to give
you three now we need some new notation
here you actually all know this number
we call it the square root of three
right if you multiply the square root 3
by the square root of three you get a
three okay
in fact that's what square root means
it's the number that you multiply it by
itself and it will give you back this
guy okay let's push forward let's have a
look at some other fractions let's try
for instance so this is example one
let's do example two let's go through
the number like say five okay let's take
a different fraction up there okay let's
do a third okay okay now I want to try
and do a similar kind of trick pull
something out of a hat like this so I
can work out what five ^ 1/3 whatever
that is what's it equal to okay so I'm
gonna multiply by something any
suggestions what should I do
multiple by seven but would you get much
meaningful out of that I'm not multiply
it by itself okay now for reasons that
will become clear in a second I'm gonna
multiply it by itself one more time
three times rather than to you I wonder
if you can see where I'm going okay
okay hold on be careful about your
numbers right it is about the
denominator multiply numbers all with
the same base so what I do with the
indices I'm gonna add them okay so I've
got 1/3 plus 1/3 plus 1/3 again that's
one isn't it so 5 to the power of 1 is 5
so I've got some number and when I
multiply it by itself 3 times I end up
with 5 ok well here we call this the
square root right if you square 3 the
square root 3 you get the 3 okay we call
this a different um it's not square root
is it it's called the cube root we write
it like this in a very similar way we
write it with a 3 outside there I read
that as the cube root of 5 okay we're
here because it's this this
multiplication tip if I added these
together I wouldn't get 5 I have to
multiply them together to get 5 do you
mean this 3 or this 3 okay so that 3
there indicates it's not the square root
that's what it usually means it's the
cube root and I can actually keep going
I could not just have a square root or
the cure I have different other kinds of
well not twos or threes but let's let's
do some other crazy pick okay let's do
10 here's my third example okay this
time I'm gonna go to let's try this
lawyer instead because I don't want to
write this out ten times okay let's go 7
to the power of one tenth okay now if I
multiply this number by itself 10 times
see that that's multiplied whatever's in
there by itself 10 to
okay according to this lawyer here one
two three four okay this is power of a
power so what do I do to the indices I
multiply them rank you see what's going
on
so that's 1/10 times 10 that's just
setting the power of 1 which is 7 okay
so what's going on here this number is
the number that you multiply by itself
10 times to give you 7 I would call that
rather than the square root or the cube
root on the call of the well I call I
just call it the tenth blue okay because
the numbers gonna keep going 11 through
12th root whatever okay that's what's
going on okay that's a really big
example you don't really need to worry
about that but I'm just showing you you
can these are main important ones we're
gonna see here one of that's the wind
taking out power station
okay so you've got the square e there
and the cube root there okay sir let's
bring this back to our list of laws okay
which again it's not just why are these
true just because we said so they're
true because you can see that's how the
rules of the game work okay so I'm gonna
write in these two a to the power of 1/2
when you see that ok what that really
means is hmm the square root of 8 okay
so if I gave you as an example a hundred
to the power of 1/2 that's a square in
100 which is squared 100 what's the
number that you multiply by itself to
give you a hundred multiply multiply it
it's ten okay and you calculator can do
these two you can do the square root I
exactly the same way this is kind of
like the same more but with another
number if you see any power of a third
it's not the square root it's the cube
root okay so for instance one of the key
numbers I know if I gave you this
example 64 to the power of 1/3 okay now
you might not know this number off the
top yet and that's okay
you know but it's the cube root of 64
there's a number if you multiply it by
itself three times you'll get 64 does
anyone know what it is well twelve times
twelve times twelve that's going to be
144 times 12 which I think he's gonna be
oh man
I shouldn't have done this this is 1440
plus 288 it's one seven two eight
that's not 64 it's way too big must be
something much smaller yeah four four
let's try four more times four times
four you do the first pair what's 4
times fit 16 16 times 4 if you do those
that's 40 if you do those it's 20 point
at 64 would the cube root of 64 is 4
okay that's a less common number but now
you recognize it okay so you can use
that as an example all right no brothers
that's okay whenever you are unsure okay
I'll get your calculator out and you
will actually see okay you've got your
square button and right next to it is
the square root so you did there beside
each other you've got a cube button and
just below that is the cube root button
so you can use that as well
okay so for instace let's see this is
going to be let's try this I think it's
okay now what's the cube root of 25
dunno
okay so you get your you get your
calculator out okay and on mine it looks
like it's right above the square root
button go shift square root and you can
even see that little cube root icon
appears okay then you slap in your 125
and you hit equals and what do you get
say again
5
now by the way you can test this out if
it's the cube root that means if I
multiply it by itself three times
if I multiply it by itself three times
I should go back to the original number
125 five times five times five that's 25
times five
sure enough that's hundred twenty-five
you can check it out okay so in summary
you are these fractions in the index
you're going to get square roots of cube
roots or tenth roots or some number like
that okay the most important ones that
you see our way you got to the car
behalf order the power of third